You'll know you're on the right track
if other people are like, "Wow, this
person is doing something really
interesting and they want to talk about
it." That's a sign you're on the right
track.
>> This is Dalton Plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about how startup
founders get rich quick. And we're going
to try to I was going to say we're going
to try to keep a straight face.
We're going to try to keep straight
faces. So, Dalton, what is the
three-part recipe? Please deliver.
>> Yeah, I I think the way I would set this
up is there's the
wide perception of something and then
there's the reality. And I think a lot
of people in the world think of being a
startup founder as sort of a
get-rich-quick scheme where you kind of
show up and you promise some fake stuff
and you wave your hands and then somehow
someone gives you a bunch of money. It's
like really easy and it happens really
fast.
>> Happens every day.
>> And I think the theme of a lot of the
videos that we put out over the years is
to sort of dispel those myths or at
least be honest about how the sausage is
made here, right? And so, the point of
this video is let's talk about some case
studies of people that did get rich
quick and what they did and see if
there's anything actionable in there or
not.
>> Or if it was all right place, right
time. I wouldn't bet my life on it.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It's funny cuz I I think in my career I
actually have
both examples and it's really quite
funny that it happened that way. So,
there's Twitch which took 5 years for us
to even figure out what we needed to do
and then another set of years to
actually sell.
And there's Social Cam
which the public story is, right? Like
we spun out Justin.tv and sold within 6
months, right? So, like boom, boom,
boom. For me, I remember a story when I
was first starting when I was 23 years
old and we had um our lawyer at Wilson
Sonsini who who 30. And first I thought
that's impossibly old. That's you're
you're an ancient person. And the lawyer
said very calmly, hey, just so you
understand, you know,
we do a lot of startups. We've done kind
of a bit of a study and it turns out it
takes about 8 to 12 years to exit your
company. Something that when we say that
to ourselves, we're like, no, that lines
up. And I remember thinking this old
30-year-old has no idea
what he's talking about. There's no way
this is going to take 8 to 12 years.
I've never spent 8 to 12 years
>> When [laughter] you're when you're young
>> College was 4 years.
>> like impossibly long.
>> [laughter]
>> And nobody does the same thing in
college for 4 years.
>> No.
>> So I just remember thinking, old people
don't understand. I will tell you, we
sold the company 8 years later. Yeah. I
was then 30.
>> And I was like, ah.
>> Turns out you were right. And so I think
that this idea
um
one is so verifiably untrue.
But two, to be honest, I think it's
>> part of the reason why people get into
it.
>> Yeah. Right? Like let's unpack that.
Like how many people right now are in
year one of those startups and they're
like, if I really knew this was 8 years,
I'd quit today.
>> Have you ever heard that old engineering
saying,
we do this not because it's easy,
but because we thought it would be.
>> [laughter]
>> And I think I think that's startups. I
think if I had to summarize the whole
thing, if I had to summarize everything
about about technology, the the whole
industry,
is people thinking something will be
easy and then they get in and they and
they keep going for some reason.
>> Well, cuz once you're in
>> Well, and and like I don't want to
belittle this. Like I don't think like I
want people to do startups.
Right? So I'm not trying to convince
everyone that startups are so hard
they're not worth doing.
But on the flip side, once you're doing
a startup, I don't want you to lie to
yourself.
>> Yeah.
>> I think that's the big challenge. It's
like when you lie to yourself,
you then look for shortcuts, you look
for hacks, you look for ways that like
you can get value your customer doesn't
because you're like you would know
logically that if this was a long-term
plan it wouldn't work. But when you lie
to yourself like, "Oh, well, I could do
this for a couple years and then we'll
sell.
If we make $10 million we can sell
really easily." Yeah, you could tell
yourself this kind of fake story.
So, how do you How do you live with that
duality? I think
a lot of founders
have this hidden secret thought that
they want to hide from everyone.
>> Uh-oh.
>> Especially investors.
>> Especially investors. The parents in the
room.
>> Um
which is they really just want to get
rich quick and sell their company fast
and cash out and they don't actually
want to be a in it for the long haul.
>> The idea of IPOing a company is the last
thing on their mind.
>> And so they're like, "Man, I know I'm
not supposed to admit this."
>> Otherwise they wouldn't give me millions
of dollars.
>> Otherwise I wouldn't be able to raise my
you know. And so this is my like
I'll you know, maybe
give me some drinks and I'll tell my
friends
>> It's my dark secret.
>> Yeah.
And
I think the perhaps surprising thing I
would say is
oh, we know.
>> And so here's the point. Is it's
actually extremely midwit
to think that this is a secret and that
your job is to pretend that you want to
build a big company and and like you'll
fool everyone and somehow it'll work
out.
>> Midwit's the exact right term because
you're better off being dumb and just
assuming building a big company's easy.
Like you're actually better off
[laughter]
than being like, "No, I found the hack."
>> Like Yeah, I feel like, "Oh, I got into
YC and I told them I was going to build
a big company but I'm not." Like if you
think that that's some like
cutting edge strategy that like you
invented
>> No.
>> I've got news for you.
>> Sorry.
>> We know.
>> Yeah.
>> And so
you should just accept that and then
flip this around and be the actually
if you really genuinely like if you
could read my mind and you're like
Dalton, how would I get rich quick with
a startup?
It's
to do the opposite of what everyone else
is doing.
>> Yeah.
>> And if everyone else is trying to like
fake their way through things and not
build real value or
be in it for the long haul. If you build
real value, you stand out from the crowd
and counterintuitively, those are the
people who make a lot of money really
fast. Do you get what I'm saying? Like
go ahead, man.
>> Well, I think what's so funny is that
like AI helps and hurts. I think that
like if you're actually trying to create
real value
AI makes it so you could do it faster.
And that's really exciting. If you're
not trying to create real value, AI
makes it so you could do it really much
faster. Um and so I think that I have
certainly seen conversations where
companies would want to acquire a
founder in the first year.
>> Yes.
>> Because that founder did something
extremely interesting.
And I promise you that those
conversations are rarely about companies
that went from zero to
100 million ARR in 3 weeks. Yeah, that's
not the profile.
>> If you're just building cookie-cutter
slop
>> Yeah.
>> B2B agent stuff and your plan is to like
get rich quick. I'm just saying
there is no market for that startup.
>> No.
>> But if you do something truly weird or
different that requires you putting
yourself out there and really trying
>> Yes. Yeah, it's actually possible for
you to get rich quick.
>> And with the provisor that you're not
raising tons of money and burning tons
of money cuz these are not these deals
we're talking about are not
billion-dollar deals. These are, you
know, acquire pluses.
>> Yeah, I mean to give you a a couple of
examples, there was a company that I was
in the interview we accepted to YC in
like 2020 and the founder was building
like a
niche social network, you know, that
didn't go anywhere, and he pivoted to
this thing called Bun, which was a
JavaScript runtime compiler thing, and
he would post about it constantly,
and it was like really interesting. Like
he was an interesting guy doing
interesting things, and then Anthropic
bought Bun
for, you know, a decent amount of money,
and so he just
I don't know if that was quick, like 4
years, but basically, I think he got
extremely rich, and he did the dream
that I think a lot of founders secretly
want, which is to get Anthropic to buy
their company for 40 million or whatever
in Anthropic shares. How did he do it?
It wasn't by like brainstorming on how
to fool people.
>> Spamming infinite people with email.
>> Or like networking. It's that he built a
really kick-ass
JavaScript tool that earned the respect
of other builders.
Right?
>> Yeah.
>> And so he did it, guys. Like if you
wanted if you wanted to replicate
getting acquired by Anthropic in 3 or 4
years,
do that.
>> I mean, I keep on bringing this point up
in every video. You can actually just
look at every public Anthropic
acquisition
and ask yourself the question, "What did
they do?"
>> Yes.
And [laughter] and was it a lot of
networking
>> Yeah, yeah. Does it align with what
you're doing?
>> Like what's What is your secret strategy
to get acquired? Does that look like the
stuff that Anthropic's been acquired?
>> Like what's so funny is they're
basically saying there's alpha in just
looking at the facts, because so many
people are deluded.
>> Yes.
>> And and that delusional story is so
attractive, they don't want to look at
the facts. They don't want to learn the
truth.
And so you can stick out even more.
It's a weird thing that you can stick
out even more just creating value right
now.
>> Yeah, and like think about like Open
Claw. It's like some guy in Europe who
was like an indie hacker for 10 years,
and he just built this cool open-source
company,
and then, you know, got bought for a ton
of money. I guess he got he got rich
quick.
>> That's for 10 years of work.
Yeah.
>> You know, he was not trying to get
acquired. He was just building really
interesting stuff. And it happened
really fast.
>> I'll end on this. One of the ways you
can avoid this trap is to actually
build something you like, build
something you want to use, or build for
people and customers that you like.
>> It's so easy to get into the I want to
try to figure out how to pick an idea
that VCs will fund even though I hate
it, but that's okay because I'll do this
fast flip thing that doesn't ever
happen. And you're just kind of like
you're tricking yourself here. It's like
it's way easier to enjoy the thing
you're doing.
>> And the investors know. Again, this is
our point is you're not fooling anyone.
You're actually just fooling yourself if
that's your secret plan.
>> Like who are you fooling?
>> We have we have factored that in. And
and often times what's fun and I'll
bring it back to Twitch.
Twitch pivoted into the thing that
Emmett actually liked. Like even if
you're running your company now,
you can just pivot into the thing that
you enjoy doing.
And counterintuitively, you might have
massively increased your chances of
getting rich.
>> [laughter]
>> It's like it's sitting right there.
>> Yeah.
>> And and how many jobs are like that? How
many jobs are like, you know, if I came
into work and just do what I wanted to
do,
I might win.
>> Yeah, what if I ignored all authority
figures and I just built something
awesome
>> Yes.
>> with no other plan
that's actually good.
>> That actually works.
>> Look [laughter] that works.
>> So with that being said, um
getting rich quick happens. Don't expect
it. It's not frequent. A lot of luck
involved. But damn, it's so much easier
when you're doing something that you
like and that actually is good.
>> And that earns the respect of other
builders. Like basically, you'll know
you're on the right track
if other people are like, "Wow, this
person is doing something really
interesting." And they want to talk
about it. That's a sign you're on the
right track. All right. Great chat. All
right, thanks Michael.